Guten Tag. Karakulak ist mein Name und ich bin der Dienstarbe in der Arsau diese Station und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Hallo.
Guten Abend.
Also bevor wir über Ihre Aktele besprechen, möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Also wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Judith Lehmann.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname bestabieren?
Judith, wie so wie man das ausspricht, Jot, Uwe Ute, Devedora, Evida, Theodor Hans, Judith.
Und Nachname?
Lehmann, das ist Ludwig Emil Heinrich, Marta, Anton, Noppol, Lehmann.
Okay, sovor Lehmann, oder?
Vor Lehmann genau.
Vor Lehmann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 32 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 13. März, 82.
82.
Oder ne 92, 92.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,63 m.
62 und wie viel wegen Sie so seid?
Ungefähr 65 kg.
65 kg.
Und wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, Frau Lehmann?
Aber seit 2 Tagen, du nehmende Unterbauchschmerzen.
Und das hat jetzt richtig zugenommen.
Und die Schmerzen sind ganz heftig.
Und daher wollte ich nochmal vorbeikommen.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Okay, könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie erduft?
Können Sie das stellen?
Ja, das ist krampfartig.
Das kommt in Wellen, das kommt und geht.
Manchmal ist es besser, ich nehme auch Schmerztabletten.
Aber seit heute Morgen wird es immer schlimmer.
Okay, also Frau Lehmann, könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen
auf einer Schmerzskala bewerten?
Wobei 1 sehr leichter und 10 sehr starker Schmerzen bedeuten.
Also vor 2 Stunden war das wirklich sehr, sehr stark.
Das würde ich sagen als 8.
Jetzt ist es wieder ein bisschen besser.
Ich würde sagen so bei 5 oder 6.
Okay, möchten Sie ein Schmerzmittel?
Oder können Sie das...?
Ich habe Parazitamol genommen, ja.
Okay.
Und wie viel Milligramm haben Sie eingenommen?
Also ich habe 2 Tabletten von Parazitamol.
Ich glaube, das sind 500 Milligramm.
Ja, okay.
Was hat Ihnen geholfen?
Also die Schmerzen sind ein bisschen besser geworden,
aber ganz weg ist es nicht.
Strahlen Sie Schmerzen irgendwo hin, Frau Lehmann?
Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass Strahl so ein bisschen
in die rechte Leiste oder rechten Unterbauch ist.
Okay.
Mal ist es in der Mitte, mal rechts.
Und ja, und ich habe das Gefühl, mein Brauch ist richtig gebläht und dick.
Ach, okay.
Also, Frau Lehmann,
haben Sie etwas bemerkt,
dass die Schmerzen lehnt oder verschlechtert?
Kann ich nicht sagen.
Also das hat ganz plötzlich angefangen.
Es war nichts Besonderes.
Auch mit dem Essen und dem Trinken nicht.
Ich kann es nicht sagen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder müssen Sie erwähnen?
So eine leichte Übelkeit habe ich ja im Magenbereich.
Bestimmt.
Und übergeben?
Nein, übergeben habe ich mich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie viel oder fühlen Sie sich fiebig?
Nein, viel habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie eventuell, dass Sie Blechungen haben?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, nein, das habe ich auch nicht.
Was haben Sie auch nicht?
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass die Farbe Ihres Urins
der Stuhlgangs verändert?
Sie verändert?
Ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefangen.
Nein, also das ist eigentlich alles unverändert.
Okay.
Im letzter Zeit haben Sie zu oder abgenommen?
Ich meine in sechs Monaten?
Nein, ist alles gleich.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Herzstuppen, Herzlasen oder Herzklopfen?
Nein, mit dem Herz habe ich bisher überhaupt
nicht.
Nein.
Okay.
Und haben Sie, hatten Sie schon
einige Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, das ist das erste Mal.
So was habe ich noch nie gesagt.
Okay.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Also mit dem Schlafen habe ich überhaupt
keine Probleme.
Und wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Ja gut, bis vor zwei, drei Tagen war das noch sehr gut.
Jetzt natürlich deutlich weniger.
Ja, deutlich weniger.
Sie haben eventuell, dass Sie Unterbauchschmerzen haben.
Wo sind diese Schmerzen genau?
Also in der linken Seite oder rechten Seite?
Ja gut, das habe ich schon gesagt.
Sie sind ja in der Mitte oft, aber manchmal
strahlt es auch in der rechten Leiste aus.
Okay.
Haben Sie Sotrennen oder Sauerstoßen?
Nein, nur eine Leichtüblichkeit.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Lehmann, sind bei Ihnen
irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Wie ist zum Beispiel Zurückkrankkeit,
Bluthochdruck oder Schildhörse
unter der Überfunktion?
Nein, von all dem habe ich nichts, aber ich habe vor drei Jahren
eine Diagnose für eine Rheumatoide-Artritis bekommen.
Und das heißt, ich nehme auch Immun-Supressiva.
Das sind moderne Spritzen, die ich einmal die Woche benutze.
Wissen Sie der Name von der Spritze?
Das habe ich jetzt vergessen, muss ich noch mal nachgucken.
Neues Biologikum, weiß ich nicht, aber ich weiß nicht genau,
wie oft müssen Sie diese Spritze?
Einmal die Woche.
Eine Woche, okay.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Nein, dann sonst nichts.
Habt ihr von der Rheumatoide-Artritis gesehen,
haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein, nein.
Und wurden Sie schon mal operiert, Frau Lehmann?
Nein, bisher nicht, nee.
Okay.
Und während dieser Medikamente-Therapie nehmen Sie auch
Magelschutz-Tablette?
Nein, habe ich bisher nicht gebraucht, nein.
Okay.
Und sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unfältiglichkeit bekannt?
Nein, ich habe gegen Polen Allergie, die ist sehr ausgeprägt.
Im Frühjahr habe ich sehr starke Schnupfen und Augenbrennen.
Ansonsten habe ich keine anderen Allergie.
Okay.
Und Frau Lehmann, waufen Sie?
Selten, also fast nicht mehr.
Selten. Was meinen Sie mit Selten?
Ja, wenn eine Feiermal ist oder so, aber regelmäßig jeden Tag rauche ich jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Was zünken Sie mit Alkohol?
Auch sehr selten, ja.
Selten, okay.
Und haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen, nein, also meine höchste oder schlimmste Droge ist in Schokolade.
Okay.
Und wenn ich einmal anfange, kann ich nicht aufhören.
Aber ansonsten, nein, nein, brauche ich nicht.
Und sind Sie gegen sowohl Kinderkrankheit als auch Corona schon vorständig geimpft?
Ja, ja, also mein Haushalt kontrolliert das immer.
Und er sagt, ich habe alle meine Impfungen.
Die nächsten sind erst in fünf Jahren.
Sind Sie in nächster Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, nein.
Und Ihre Monatsblutung ist regelmäßig?
Ja, also bisher war dann kein Problem, das ist regelmäßig.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Frauen als regelmäßig?
Ich habe nur nicht Probleme, das letzte war vor drei Jahren ungefähr.
Ich gehe dann in die Impfung.
Könnte es sein, dass Sie schwärmiger sind?
Nein, nein, nein.
Noch nicht, hat Zeit.
Okay.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, und die sind auch gesund, denen geht es gut, also da gibt es keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein.
Nein, okay.
Und was machen Sie behauptlich, Frau Lehmann?
Ich bin Arzt-Härferin.
Ah, okay.
Arbeit in einer Praxis.
Haben Sie viel Stress auf der Arbeit?
Ein Was?
Ja, natürlich.
Unser Chef ist auch ein etwas schwieriger Mensch, aber ja, wir haben viele Patienten, es gibt viel zu tun.
Also stressen wir jeden Tag.
Ja, wir stehen, ja.
Wir haben auch Frau Lehmann.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Ich habe einen Freund, wir leben schon seit über 10 Jahren zusammen.
Okay.
Ja, also, Frau Lehmann.
Und ich denke, ihr habt alle Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie Fragen oder möchte ich jetzt...
Ja, ich möchte, ich sehe es was Schlimmes oder nicht, ich weiß es nicht.
Also es macht mir Sorgen.
Also ich kann auch seit zwei Tagen nicht arbeiten.
Ich würde natürlich schon gern wissen, wie schlimm das ist.
Ob es mal ein Darminfekt ist oder ob es etwas anderes sein kann.
Also...
Daher wollte ich einfach nochmal...
Ich habe auch...
Ich habe auch vergessen zu fragen, ja, ich habe ja fragen.
Also Frau Lehmann, jetzt zuzeit im Moment kann ich nicht etwas genau sagen,
aber es könnte sein entweder eine Nierenprobleme
oder eine, wie soll ich sagen,
diese Eistrufe.
Okay.
Ja, Beileitenprobleme sein,
aber deswegen sollen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Das wäre sehr nett, ja.
Das habe ich auch ergekommen, dass man...
Ja, ja, ja.
Zuerst werde ich die Köpfele untersuchen,
dann ein paar Labo-Untersuchungen durchführen,
danach werde ich ein paar Bekleber und Labo-Untersuchungen durchführen.
Okay.
Das machen Sie alles noch heute Abend, oder?
Ja, ja, ja.
Sie müssen mindestens zwei Stunden...
Ach, ja, ich.
Ich gehe schneller.
Aber vielen Dank, dass Sie mich so schnell auch dran genommen haben,
ohne dass ich so lange warten musste.
Ich hoffe, dass kommt nichts Schlimmes dabei raus.
Ja, wir hoffen auch.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Dankeschön.
Seit sehr, sehr gut, für zehn Minuten.
Ich habe Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen.
Ich bin zilllos.
Alles klar?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, Problem.
Haben Sie Blut im Stuhl oder ungewöhnliches Bemer?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Also, das war bis vor zwei Tagen alles in Ordnung.
Ich weiß nicht, woher das kommt.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind geübt, ja.
Okay.
Können Sie als erstes ein Anfang machen?
Ja, ich komme.
Also, ja.
Guten Tag, Herr Obas.
Guten Tag, Herr Kara Kulak.
Guten Abend.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Wenn Sie Zeit hätten, würde ich Ihnen über Sie berichten.
Können wir gerne machen, bitte schon erzählen Sie mal.
Sie heißt Judith Lehman.
Sie ist 32 Jahre alt, 1,63 m groß und 65 kg schwer.
Sie hat sich bei uns wegen seit zwei Tagen progrediert.
Sie hat eine sehr kompetente, kraftartige,
wellenformige Abtummi-Unterbauchschmerzen
mit Strahlung in den rechten Leisten vorgestellt.
Der Patient berichtet, dass die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala bei 8.
Und dagegen nehme er Basilica 500 mg.
Nehmen Sie Basilica 500 mg zweimal.
Aber das hat sie, das hat ihr ein bisschen geholfen.
Außerdem berichtet die Patientin, dass die Schmerzen plöster angefangen haben.
Und des Weiteren klackte die Patientin über Nausea mit Tourismus
und die Fragen nach Emesis, Fieber,
Miction und Defekationsprobleme wurden verneint.
Emesis hat sie doch, oder?
Emesis hat sie nicht.
Sie hat nur Nausea.
Anfall Erkrankungen leidete die Patientin seit drei Jahren
um die Schmerzkala zu erheben.
Sie hat auch eine Spitzkala.
Was war eine Spitzkala?
Der Name der Spitzkala weiß sie nicht.
Okay.
Oder gucken wir noch mal nach.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein neues Präparat, diese Biologika.
Bei der Patientin wurde keine Operation durchgeführt.
Bei der Patientin ist eine Polynalegie bekannt, die sich rennet und konjuktivisiert.
Okay.
Sie raucht selten und trinkt auch selten Alkohol.
Die Frage nach Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Die Impfstatus ist vorbeständig.
Die Reise an einem Nase war unauffällig.
Und die Genekolikische Anamnese ist auch unauffällig.
Okay.
Die Familienanamnese ist auch unauffällig.
Sie ist Arzhelferin, Wohnberuf.
Sie hat viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Aufgrund der analistischen Angaben gehe ich von Renal-Kollig.
Was?
Renal kann ein Urulithiasis sein.
Urulithiasis.
Er hat vielleicht eine Gastroenteritis.
Er hat Unterbauchschmerzen.
Er kann auch eine Morbus-Kone sein.
Er kann natürlich ein Zeichen von einer chronisch entzündlichen
Datenbefragung sein.
Wenn Sie Unterbauchschmerzen haben,
dann kann man auch eine Myo-Kone sein.
Eine Myo-Kone kann so etwas machen, als etwas Gynäkologisches.
Eine Zystitis.
Zystitis kann auch mal solche Beschwerden machen.
Um mein Veradachternuss zu bestätigen,
werde ich die Patientin köpferlich untersuchen.
Und bei der Labor-Untersuchung werde ich
eine Zylopropyl-Beske.
Und ja.
Was noch? Die Nierenwerte? Leberwerte?
Ja, ja, ja.
Die Nierenwerte.
Gleich noch die Schildrösenwerte,
falls man CT oder noch braucht.
Oder brauchen wir auch Outraschalt.
Das ist richtig.
Also gegenwärts eine Bauch-CT des Abdomens.
Wobei bei einer jungen Frau,
würde man statt ein CT machen.
Ein MRT, wenn es geht.
Okay, sehr gut.
Schauen wir mal, was rauskommt.
Wenn Sie die Ebene haben,
dann rufen Sie mich wieder einmal an.
Alles klar, vielen Dank.